in this episode we'll meet taryn
southern a storyteller whose own
personal story will take us on a journey
from art to artificial intelligence and
from stem cells to brain machine
interfaces and we'll find out why she
remains optimistic about the future of
humanity
[Music]
for your entire career from youtube to
vr to ai to now neurotech it seems like
you're always at the forefront of the
new technology that is about to be huge
how does that happen why are you always
right there
oh man that's i don't know if i'm always
right there sometimes i feel like i'm a
little too early and then i wish i would
have waited a few months for things to
catch up but
i i grew up in wichita kansas which is
you know it's not exactly the capital of
innovation in the world
um and i was really drawn to technology
from a very young age because it was my
window to the outside world you know i
remember logging on dial up style to aim
to meet people around the world
and to learn
about what was happening in places that
i had never seen or been and just
feeling so excited about the
connectivity that we had access to i
remember doing my first painting in like
an ms dos
software system
i think i composed my first piece of
music with some archaic music composer
just using my keypad so it's always been
it's always been this sort of intuition
or second language for me to use
technology as a means to engage with the
world or as a means to create
in a space where i don't actually have
skill sets
so
i think in that way it's very natural
for me to to experiment with all of
these different technologies so at that
young age when you were first kind of
exposed to the wider world through the
internet
did you have sort of like a
self-understanding of i'm a creator and
i'm going to use technology as my medium
not that young i just i was highly
creative
um when i wasn't busy tinkering on my
computer i was building model airplanes
with my dad
shadow boxes for my hamsters so that
they could have beautiful little worlds
to engage in got to get them out of the
cage
um i would make my own clothes for my
barbies so i i suppose i was just
interested in creation of all forms
but i didn't have i didn't have a lot of
formal training of any kind um i was not
a dancer i was not a musician
so i was forced i think
to look at these
more advanced technological tools in
order to facilitate my desire to create
in those spaces so from other worlds
from your hamsters to youtube
yeah um
i think
i'm gonna make an assumption for women
on the internet sometimes technology is
not always a good thing so how did you
balance the promise of you know a
creative outlet that was this new
youtube platform and the perils which is
sometimes being connected to the wider
world isn't always fun
great question and i actually learned my
first lesson
in that
i was 16 years old i had built a website
for my beanie babies collection
obviously
i had taught myself html from message
boards
and about two months after this website
was up and i had built these really
adorable sparkly gifts where the beanie
babies are rotating
obviously
and apparently ty the parent company of
beanie babies was not very happy about
this so i received a copyright
infringement letter telling me that i
was going to be sued i'm 16 years old i
am terrified i get this very
nasty worded email and my dreams of
becoming a computer engineer were shot
overnight
um but i learned an important lesson
from that and that lesson has carried on
throughout my career online which is
well there's actually a couple of
lessons one is you never know how people
are going to react to even the most
benign material and when you're putting
something up online you are
you are inviting
uh reactions from anyone
and uh the second thing i learned is
that unless you take it down it's there
forever
uh and i think that those lessons
were really helpful for me when i
started my youtube channel i think i was
21 years old when i uploaded my very
first youtube video it went viral it got
me on a lot of talk shows
and it also
had its fair share of criticisms
and um
and i don't know i just i i kind of saw
it as this unique opportunity
to
have my creativity and my art seen by
by
these audiences that i never would have
had access to here i was like in la
fighting to get a meeting with an agent
so that i could maybe get an audition
for a tv show that i could maybe be on
and maybe be seen by a couple hundred
thousand people and on youtube i could
upload something and
for whatever reason uh millions might
watch and that was an exhilarating
opportunity
so i think i think with all of the
downsides that came along with it i was
always able to balance out
the reality which is this this is a
an incredible point of access for any
artist to do anything they want with no
restrictions so i was able to focus on
sort of the positive aspects absolutely
and i think you build thick skin over
time
but i also i don't i don't remember it
ever really getting to me
um
the the negative commentary because i
just
i don't know maybe i was just able to
tune it out there were other things
about the job that certainly got to me
that was not one that wasn't one i mean
let's be honest they gave you copyright
infringement because your website was
too good
so i feel like these days that's more of
like a compliment from the company yeah
than anything else so you were able to
kind of find your feet quite early as a
creator tell me about the jump then from
the more two-dimensional
video medium that we're maybe more
familiar with to
virtual reality
it was a big leap um i spent most of my
20s working in both traditional tv and
film as well as youtube and i think by
the end of that era it was about a
10-year run i had made several thousand
videos
and was starting to become i was already
in burnout and i was starting to become
very disillusioned about
what was necessary for me to keep up
with the hamster wheel of content and
feeling like if i don't upload every day
the algorithms are going to punish me i
will lose this whole audience that i've
built and i've been building this
audience in someone else's backyard
so i really don't actually have control
and in that moment i decided to take
some time off i was
again so burnt out i didn't even know
what i wanted to do next so i took three
or six months and i said i'm gonna play
around and just
look around at what's happening in
spaces that are interesting to me and i
happen to go to a party
a uh vr party i put on my first ever vr
headset it was an htc vive
and i think i was a little anxious that
day about something that was going on i
don't remember what but i slipped into
this beautiful expansive underwater
world in the middle of a party with
hundreds of people and i felt my heart
rate slow
and this almost meditative
experience take over
and i thought i don't know what this is
or how they make it but i have to be
involved
and so i spent the next six months
learning everything i could about
virtual reality and how to make vr
content game engine content 360 video
content um i applied for a a program
with google that was like the google vr
lab with several other creators
and was part of that inaugural program
where we really learned every aspect of
vr creation including 360 spatial audio
and
we got to just play and experiment and
see what is this new medium and what
kind of impact will it have on audiences
super cool time what is different about
virtual reality in terms of the stories
that you can tell
and what you're saying the impact on
audience
very different and i mean i wish i'd had
more time to experiment than the than
the nine months that i was playing
around but i think you know with with 2d
filmmaking
the director can be very specific in
terms of the kind of experience that
they want the audience to have
uh you know they're literally picking
the exact shot that the audience is
going to see the music everything it's
all
it's all just
you are being directed through an
experience whereas with 360 vr the
participant has far more control over
what they choose to see over how did
they choose to engage depending on
the technology being used for the 360 vr
there could be multiple story lines so a
person might actually be making their
way through a story um i think that kind
of interactivity is something we've
never seen before in 2d and then on top
of that and this is where i found myself
even more fascinated with the difference
in vr is
you're able to have a greater
physiological effect on the human body
through vr content our brain
is it's this very funny object uh that
oftentimes cannot tell the difference
between
reality and virtual reality when the
environments are so photorealistic
and when you get things like spatial
audio happening
the experience becomes instantly more
immersive and we are able to embody an
experience
more frequently in virtual reality and
so this is why it can be very effective
for things treating things like ptsd
um for for
if you're looking at things like
cognitive bias
any kind of pain response trauma
response vr can be a highly effective
tool yeah retraining behaviors
retraining behaviors exactly more so
than two-dimensional content and that's
what i find fascinating do you use it
regularly now in your own life if you
need to
um perhaps you know
alter your physiological state maybe
reduce your heart rate calm down handle
some anxiety or is it something that
you've only used as a creative tool for
storytelling no i i was using it for a
while for to reach meditative states i
was in a couple of different programs
that would able me to do that sadly i
moved into a new cottage a couple of
years ago right before covid hit and
someone
burglarized my space and stole my htc
vive
so i have not actually had a headset for
the last two years and um and i'm so
curious now you know if i were to use
some of those programs how i would feel
but but a hundred percent i mean when i
was going through chemotherapy two years
ago i thought i really wish i had my
head set here right now this would just
make this whole process a lot more
enjoyable than looking at a white
hospital wall
yeah absolutely i love that you went
from creating like whole other worlds
for your hamsters to creating like 360
whole other worlds for for humans yeah
yeah and it was such a it was such a
cool process we um
my team we didn't have a lot of money
and i had already experimented with 360
video i was a little bit less excited
about 360 video in part because
the tech wasn't there yet to be able to
do
high super high resolution uh 360 video
um however game engine animation
could have this level of photo realism
that was bar none so i was like i want
to do that
and my team said well we don't have the
budget for that and so we got really
creative and we we basically
repurposed consumer animation
technologies uh google tilt brush and
google blocks
to create these beautiful immersive
worlds on a dime using some of the top
vr artists around the world who are very
good with these tools and
um the i think that the end result
turned out very well uh one of the
projects just won an att film award last
year and
um it's been recognized as a sort of a
novel use of of vr tools um to
accomplish that immersive environment so
it was a great learning experience i
mean it sounds like using the technology
as tools really
opened up a lot of possibilities for you
as a creator but you've also
collaborated with technology how do you
collaborate with the technology oh man
and this this next project was really
born out of the vr project as well um i
was looking for background music for
this vr series of vr videos
and was interested in in taking a look
at what was
currently available um from ai software
technology so i started playing around
with a handful of ai softwares and i was
like this is good like
pretty good stuff and i was really
interested in the process of creating
the music
the human ai collaboration process
and normally when i think of
normally when i think of things like ai
or vr i think of them as tools
because they are just like a paintbrush
or a piano or any other creative tool
that a human will yield and to bring
their creative vision to life but ai is
interesting because it is taking
feedback it's incorporating that
feedback it's spitting something else
back out at you and then there's like a
constant dual process happening
until one person usually the director
says we're done
um and so
yes i ended up i ended up making an
entire album with artificial
intelligence as the composer
[Music]
[Applause]
and that was highly collaborative
because there were
a handful of different ai technologies
that i used on the album that process
looked different for each one
but the easiest way to kind of break
down that creative process is to compare
it to that of a director and a producer
or a director and an editor so i was
providing the ai software with certain
parameters
like beats per minute key
uh instruments that i want in what kind
of build i want in the song is there an
emotive layer there
uh the ai would take that information
cobble something together shoot it back
at me sometimes i then provide a data
set of new material based in a certain
period of time or music space
like this i like what you did but can
you kind of combine it with this
influence and then they churn out more
material and so it the process is really
not all that different from working with
a human
you just don't get the same nuanced
dialogue
um you know you have to as a director
make sure that you can make choices
represented in zeros and ones
and code rather than
the conversation like we're having here
and were you really working with a fixed
sort of
ai paradigm or were you able to
collaborate with the human behind the
algorithm and say the algorithm is
behaving like this can we tweak it and
then can i try to iterate again
yes actually so with two three of the
three of the companies i
worked directly with the founders of the
companies in providing feedback on how
they were categorizing certain things
how the data sets were being interpreted
by the ai some of the strengths some of
the weaknesses
um
i think that you know that was a really
interesting experience for me because
i'm not an engineer but to see how those
how those
pieces of feedback could result in
engineering changes was really really
cool and they did i mean i know ampere
music
shifted some of the ways that they
categorized
music templates and allowed allowed uh
allowed people to actually build and
layer songs with single tracks which was
something any artist would need the
ability to do so it was fun to be part
of that process well it sounds like your
experience with artificial intelligence
has really been one of opening up new
opportunities but
there is sort of another way of looking
at what these machine learning
algorithms can do for us that sort of
limits human choice and i think maybe
you alluded to that when we're talking
about
as a content creator the algorithm kind
of controls how successful you are so
what's your perspective on that yeah
it's a really good question and it's i
think there's no simple answer for that
because
we almost have to look at the meta
meta layer first which is that all of us
are now subject to these algorithmic
nudges in everything that we're doing
as content creators as writers as
publishers we are incentivized by
certain models and if those models don't
change our content's only going to be
driven more and more and more toward a
certain type of
uh
shock value content or whatever it is
that we think is going to get views
um beneath that of course um
when you start working with things like
like algorithms as a as a creator on a
particular project
it is going to point out certain things
to you that you may not have seen you
know in terms of how you've structured
your video the kinds of words that
you're using i do feel like it can serve
as an important
part
important partner or co-conspirator you
know in the creative process
but you could also argue that
you know if it's anything like pop music
um
if algorithms are anything like pop
music and they start to train
over and over and over again on what the
greatest number of people like there's
an argument that everything sort of ends
up the same
sounding the same that there's more of a
box
and i don't know
which way will go i mean so far in my
experiments with ai i've been able to
jump out of the box more than feel like
i'm trapped in the box
because i'm working with algorithms that
are studying influences that i would
never have access to like
jazz and calypso music and 1800s uh
romantic period piano pieces never would
have made their way into my
into my songwriting until i started
working with ai so i think it all just
depends on the perspective that you're
looking at and how the artists are using
it but i do think that the artist has a
lot more control
than maybe what
some of the narratives are currently
around ai it's a difference between
being
the creator where you're a little bit
more in the driver's seat and the
consumer
where
the way that you interact with the
technology is kind of already described
for you that's right i think the
consumers have the least amount of power
in all of this right because
they're being fed content that the
algorithm
is happily feeding them more and more of
and then all of the other reasons why
technology is
is creating a feedback loop a positive
or negative feedback loop that they
can't get out of
but as a creator i mean you're telling
stories using technology
what are the stories that are most
important for you to tell
um
i really love to tell stories that sit
at the intersection of science and human
potential
i really love
optimistic stories i think we have
enough scary ones out there the world
can be a scary place and if i have any
hand in making
people feel a bit more hopeful about the
future then i would feel like i did my
job also because i do feel hopeful about
the future
um i really like telling stories about
humans so anytime i'm working with a
technology company and they want me to
do something about their technology i
say well who's using this what are they
getting from it and how is this
technology enabling them to do more
human things
what are human things
like love you know like
being with their husband and wife being
with their children uh playing tennis
like
all of these basic human how is this
technology maybe
freeing up more time so they can do that
or enabling them to do that better
um and we start with those questions and
then work our way backwards into the
storytelling
um and i find that that works really
well and i enjoy that process and i
think it's an important aspect um it's
it's an important thing for the
technology companies to see too yeah as
they're making the tech like are is the
is the end
is the end point of how humans will
integrate this into their world truly
being considered
and in your experience is it
i'd say
most the companies i have worked with
fortunately it is
but i could look around at dozens of
technologies that are supposed to be
human-centric but i don't feel like the
people behind
the front wheel of those cars are
actually
seeing what it's actually doing if your
intention's one thing
but the result is something entirely
different then something's gone wrong
right
well if you're talking about being able
to
use technology to allow humans to do
more human things i think you're living
proof especially from the biotechnology
side that that is absolutely something
that we can do now and do
successfully can you share a little bit
about your journey and how you leaned
into cutting-edge technology in your own
personal struggles sure so i've always
been very interested in how i could
manipulate my biology with today's
technological tools
and that could be something as basic as
like a laser that i could put on my
wrist that helps with blood circulation
it exists to
infrared light saunas to some more
intense treatments like
pluripotent stem cell injections
and um
i think it's just part of these
curiosities i i have an understanding
that we're still at the very early
stages of longevity science of
understanding how
how our bodies uh
you know how our bodies are able to keep
cells alive and well and not have these
detrimental cells swimming around in our
bodies so i started experimenting with
all of these different things i'd say
five six years ago
never
thinking in a million years that i would
end up diagnosed with stage three breast
cancer
and so
it was quite ironic maybe even a little
bit
dark comedy funny
that the girl who had done everything
to freeze her eggs
sequence her genome
uh
get multiple stem cell treatments
um and was so active in biohacking my
way through life
gets very early stage um
or i should say very late stage cancer
at an early age what's interesting is we
don't yet know all the genes responsible
for
all of the diseases i had a few
variations of unknown significance in
the breast cancer gene
they haven't
been linked yet but at some point i'm
sure they will my grandmother had breast
cancer it usually skips a generation
um and i had a strange feeling
since i was young i was like i feel like
i'm gonna end up with this darn disease
and i did
so that but it came as a big shock i was
32 years old and
was completely healthy when it happened
but because of all of these
crazy things that i had done
i was able to start treatment about two
months earlier than i normally would
have because uh the treatment that i
went through would have destroyed all of
my eggs and i had already frozen them so
that was nice congratulations
got that done
um and all of my genomic sequencing was
also very helpful in being able to
choose the right treatment uh the right
chemotherapy um regimen as a result of
having that already done and then in
terms of the stem cells i had pulled
those out of my hip bone a couple years
earlier and
why
i knew that some of the
coolest science being done in the
longevity space was on stem cells
and the older you are
the older your stem cells are so the
younger you can freeze them and bank
them i mean now parents are encouraged
to freeze the placenta of their child so
the child has the
the most plentiful young stem cells that
they can use later in life
and so as soon as i heard about this i
thought well why not just do this now
um get the stem cells as young as
possible this is quite a painful process
it was so painful
i don't recommend it no
no i regretted it immediately
um and then i felt much better after i
was diagnosed with cancer because
those because they're cells from inside
the bone they're very likely completely
untouched
um by cancer unless i had been
metastatic and so
if the cancer were to ever come back
again we would have
clean cells from my body and we would be
able to see genetically why
there was all these mutations that
happened in the breast cancer cell we're
not there yet but it will happen and
this kind of personalized treatment
i mean it's amazing that i did that
because if if it comes back i'll have
this this option that i would never have
had had i not frozen them and even if it
doesn't come back even if it doesn't
come back if i get arthritis later in
life or i have a big knee injury it's
very common that you can unfreeze these
stem cells inject it into your body it
accelerates healing
accelerates tissue development so you
know i'm just planning to just be an old
bionic woman i guess
i love that you've given yourself that
gift you can be an old bionic woman now
because of your curiosity and your
willingness to experiment with these
yeah technologies yeah so speaking of
the newest technology that maybe you're
not personally experimenting with yet
but the newest area that you're working
in
neurotech that can mean a lot of things
but are we talking about physical
implants into the human brain
yes uh why
why must we do it yes um so a couple of
years ago i directed and co-produced a
documentary on the future of the brain
and this film followed three patients
all whom had brain implants in the hopes
of restoring function there was a
paralyzed patient a blind patient and a
woman with parkinson's
all three of them had to cut open their
skull have this little tiny chip drilled
that down in there and then there's a
period of electrical stimulation through
the implant to see if you can actually
have function restored i don't want to
give away the movie but the reality is
there are currently 300 000 people
walking around the globe with
one of these one of these implants um
most of them for parkinson's it's pretty
remarkable what they're able to do
but essentially where we're at in
neurotech it's a very very exciting time
um
things like
movement hearing
vision
uh even a sense of touch can all be
restored through electrical stimulation
inside of the brain
and as we conduct more and more studies
on what's possible
uh through brain computer interfaces or
deep brain stimulation we're also
learning how these implants affect other
aspects of the brain like memory
or
treatment resistant depression and
anxiety is is one that's
being looked at right now in a lot of
clinical trials so
um it's a really exciting space i'm yes
i'm working for a company that is sort
of at the forefront of implantable brain
computer interfaces
and i think the next five to ten years
we're going to see a big
shift in public awareness around
around these technologies what they're
what they can do for people how they can
change people's lives it's gonna
take some time for that conversation to
matriculate out to the larger public
but it will happen and i think that's
why it's important to start having these
conversations now i think when you start
talking about affecting
brain function in as invasive and easy
to understand of a way as
putting an electrode into your brain and
i'm going to be able to both record and
inject current that is going to affect
the way that your brain is functioning
people start to get a little queasy and
they start to say where do i end and
where does the computer begin and then
if you go back to our earlier part of
the conversation about algorithms sort
of removing choice and restricting the
behavioral options that we have things
get to get a little dystopian and dark
and weird yeah how do you stay
optimistic
okay so i mean this is where
the whole thing starts to get very
philosophical and we have to start
looking at
who are we really and what what role
does consciousness play in our
personality because i can make an
argument that we are all just a series
of biochemical reactions i mean
i don't know if this is the best example
but i am going to use it because it is
real
is
taryn who is on pms the real taran is
that her real brain or is that just a
series of biochemical reactions causing
taryn to be more angry irritable
and deeply upsetting for others to be
around
or is the real taran the terran that is
not having these biochemical reactions
but maybe other biochemical reactions
such as lack of sleep maybe eating
something bad having an emotional
breakdown due to something at work
whatever it is right like our brains are
not this fixed continuous
state
i think most of us know what it's like
at some point in our lives to go through
anxiety or depression or some kind of
mental illness i mean the statistics
show that that is true certainly in the
last two years number of people with the
experience has increased certainly so
yeah and so i guess for me
um we've already accepted
pharmacological solutions for these
things i'm not saying that everyone
should take them or that they're even
right for anyone but as a society we've
accepted that that's generally okay
i don't think that there's a huge leap
in the imagination to say instead of
carpet bombing the brain with a
substance that is highly imprecise we're
now going to put a tiny little chip in
that's going to stimulate only the
neurons responsible for this type of
activity in the brain and mimic healthy
neuron behaviors
in my mind that almost seems like it's
bringing us closer
to who we are meant to really be
um that it's just it's fixing this sort
of biochemical process but in an
electrical way
um
and i might be over oversimplifying that
and this is also the result of me
sitting in this field for four years and
having been at one time
very
shocked
about what we could do and where we were
going
um but i think the more that i've been
around these patients the more i've seen
their lives change
the more i think about all the ways in
which we currently
um engage with
the world with various augmentations
i think it's just one of those things
that as as it proves to be safe and if
people really feel like it's just making
them the the best version of themselves
i could see it be more accepted
we spoke with a technologist katerina
fake who talks about this concept of the
technic which is like this this world
that's technologically dependent that
we're sort of like swimming in like the
way that a fish swims in their like
aquatic
medium but it sounds like what you're
discussing as like the next stage where
the fish is actually part of the
technological medium and there really is
no
boundary
could it could be that i mean
i i think the whole vision of humans
connected to their cell phones
that's not one i'm interested in or
subscribed to as like a vision of where
this could go i'm i think i'm more
interested in understanding
how we
how we can make our lives better and
most of our lives are dictated by our
brain
so it's just if there was just ways to
subtly turn some knobs so that we could
all just be more loving and
a little more calm and maybe not
at the mercy of our ancient limbic
system
uh i would be very happy with that kind
of world i actually think the world that
we're living in right now where
where we all have our smartphones with
us everywhere we go
we're connected all the time but it's
like with this external thing that's
nudging us and poking us and notifying
us and not giving us a break i find that
i find that version of reality really
toxic
and
far more scary than the idea of putting
a chip in my brain that
that maybe makes me just a little bit
feel more like myself hmm
i don't remember where i heard this but
i heard it once i was like that is
genius and now i keep using it like it's
my phrase but that our brains evolve to
keep us alive not make us happy
yeah
i love that quote and i think it's so
true and by the way i think that there's
something inherently human about
grief and anger and uh and joy and
experiencing all the things so i'm by no
means an advocate of erasing
i think what it means to be human
um and the human experience so i don't
know how we're gonna figure out
i don't know how we're gonna figure out
who sets the rules and the paradigms
around this and what really counts as
you know improving someone's brain by
ten percent versus just
making sure that they're not losing
function in ways that are uncomfortable
uh it's an interesting it's a really
interesting question
and i say that as someone who's been to
a lot of therapy and doesn't shy away
from
healing whatsoever doesn't shy away from
confronting hard realities
um but i i'm i'm most fascinated by that
component part of the the conversation
how do we ameliorate mental
health and mental illness
through these devices
so i'm not if i'm not in the driver's
seat if i'm not the content creator and
i'm a consumer how could i protect
myself against some of these downsides
it's really hard because it's very easy
for any of these technologies to hijack
the brain and so it's all about
developing an awareness around what's
happening how something is making you
feel and then making concerted choices
against that um even if it goes against
your instinct so for instance with
social media one of the first things
that i did years ago was turn off all
notifications i don't get sounds i don't
get dings i don't have anything flipping
up on my phone i have to make the choice
to log into the
the app in order to see any kind of
notification or message some people find
that unfathomable i feel like that is
the only way i can live
my life without
feeling this constant um low-grade
anxiety that people are reaching out to
me i do the same thing with email my
email's on push only so i do not get
notifications on email uh i often change
my phone to grayscale because just the
very act of having a phone with lots of
colors uh stimulates our dopamine
response in our brain and so that's a
one way to just make the phone
altogether less interesting
that's a great idea i'm gonna do that as
soon as we're done talking yes and then
setting hard rules around when to not be
on the phone when not to be online we
know that even just the light the led
screen from our phone affects our
circadian rhythms and our melatonin
cycles and so it's a really good idea to
have none of that
um present after 7 pm because it affects
your sleep so those are a handful of the
things that i do there's a ton more
science around that and how we can how
we can prevent ourselves from becoming
victims to
you know the dreaded technology
uh overlords but i think that those are
really helpful and then the final the
final thing which is
not something that we have maybe a lot
of individual say over but collectively
we do have power and that's in changing
incentive models for businesses away
from this attention
uh attention model um and i think some
some of the projects that are happening
right now in the blockchain space aim to
ameliorate that we'll see what happens
but i think that people are sort of fed
up with having their data owned and
their activity tracked and they want
they want a new paradigm so there's
literally no greater reward than
dopamine
so feels so good it does
i don't think the attention model will
necessarily go away just because that's
how we're wired right we're wired that
way but the awareness part is the most
critical part just like meditation it's
knowing when you're in a dopamine
feedback loop i can tell when i want to
scratch the itch by going on instagram
instagram is the death of me
it really is like i that's that is where
i get sucked in everyone's got their
thing
it makes sense it's a very visual medium
yeah and then the other part of this is
if you find yourself sucked into a
particular type of social media be very
aware with what what content you're
feeding into your brain it's taking
suggestions from everything around you
and if you're on instagram for two hours
a day and you're looking at material
that's
sort of depressing or angry or
polarizing chances are your physiology
is going to follow suit so um a couple
years ago i changed all of my follows to
tiny houses cats and motivational quotes
that's hacking your dopamine system
right there i love that yeah
so we were talking a little bit about
the ways that technology helps in
storytelling and also how it can help us
be better humans and one of the most
human things that we can possibly do is
tell stories i mean that's how we
communicate so taran the creator and the
storyteller can you
use your humanity to tell me a story
about what the future is going to look
like
i see a future
where
we are
in much more control of our
physiological states because we have an
understanding of the inputs that are
driving them
we can wake up in the morning and
through a simple urination in the toilet
we know exactly what nutrients
micronutrients are available in our
bodies we put on our brain
head brain training headset to see
what's happening in our brain waves and
we're looking at our our sleep and we're
able to walk into the day feeling like
we know how to attack that day today
we're feeling more creative today
we are um
maybe in a high focus mode maybe today
is just to sit in television and cry day
but just we're using technology as a
means to optimize our human experience
on the daily and i see content
and the ways that we engage with content
as as being much more of a choice for us
and
content linking to our physiological
states so if we're going through a
devastating breakup we might have access
to all of this content that we know will
uplift
and
um inspire and maybe start to shift
people back into a more positive mental
state while also enjoying fun content
so i think that there's going to just be
this whole
drive toward improving the human
experience in all ways
you know and i also imagine that our
homes are going to be
built using synthetic biology and
there's going to be plants growing out
of everywhere and beautiful wood
materials and we're just i feel like
life will take on
actually more vibrancy and more life
and it will be
focused on on the human experience
rather than on the technological tools
the tools will just become
the way in to the experience i think
that's a beautiful
future to be
shooting for it means a beautiful goal
right but one of my favorite things
about that vision is that you took me
from
your first interaction with the internet
and learning to use technology to
communicate with the outside world
to
using technology to better communicate
with yourself
and i think that's a lovely place to end
thank you
i want to thank taryn southern and our
other experts for participating in this
enlightening series on the promises and
perils of technology
they've illuminated an amazing array of
technologies
while all of our experts recognize that
there are some serious perils they note
that technology really could offer
viable solutions to many of the problems
defining this century and beyond
however
all of us bear the responsibility of
facing the perils and ensuring the
promises
only by staying engaged and making
conscious choices personally and as a
society can we guide the tools we have
developed into the creation of a
brighter future
[Music]